same high school and you're a new level
here have not earned teammate status yet
who the hell are you Oh Jake
Bradford until you do you're nobody by
like to introduce you the new guys to
rules no booze in this house number two
no girls upstairs in those bedrooms I'm
seriously worried about this new guys Oh
play a game we have a little tradition
welcoming the new guys practice welcome
to the big time boys look at what we
have here
hey ladies party later Ned the baseball
houses you should be investing with
energy elsewhere
my husband's really cook like that Maxie
there's nothing here yeah I can see how
that could get threatening new guy
coming in getting all the ladies as a
joke a joke right here
did he just call it a joke that's what
he implied
how did you know what room I was in I'm
an investigative journalism major so I
guess you know my name then yes soon as
you tell me starting to have an identity
crisis we've danced at a disco dance the
cotton eyed Joe and kicker attire and
here we are punks for a night you gotta
embrace your inner strange man he's be
weird
about finding out who you are you got to
hand man you guys want to try a little
telepathic stuff do it [ __ ] what am I
thinking about baseball having a tail
cereal see my sharks
um sharks have tails good point it's
good push I did tail yeah tap the house
I'm pretty sure that that is a new
school record
Lucas reason am flesh I'll stagger to be
proven to me later let's get Nick out
stank